each subsequent movie we you know they
perfect the techniques of fur an
environment and everything the first the
first movie was very challenging for the
studio not only was it their first film
but what we were asking we were saying
we were telling a story with animals fur
to animals in an exterior environment in
a natural environment and all those
things really hadn't been done so much
so that was very challenging to them but
they roasted the challenge they did it
quite miraculously but if you look at
the first feature in our feature you can
see a lot of it was much more simplistic
the styles were simplistic I think Steve
can speak to that absolutely even to
camera work I remember on the first ice
age and I was only there observing the
very end of it there was a limitation to
how many shots the camera could actually
move you know it was like a sixty
percent needed to be locked off cameras
which meant that you can only had to
render the background for one frame and
now we're in a world where I think the
industry in general you know the game
has gone much further and I think our
storytelling is such where we want the
audience to participate in the movement
of the camera and to be immersed into
that action so thankfully nobody gave us
that limitation as we started this
picture but I think to your point and
the biggest thing the most important
thing really is character and story and
environments it all looks supposed to
look great and it has to look great but
if you don't have characters that are
compelling and relatable and a story
that really is worth telling then it
doesn't matter how beautiful your movie
looks so as far as the technical aspects
ago you're right they have changed but
our characters to speak to the
characters hopefully have stayed
truthful choose truthfully truthful to
themselves you know Laurie and Michael
Berg worked on the initial story and it
was a great first draft as Mike Michael
and I first looked at the story we sat
down we said look we're in a fourth you
know version of Ice Age stories you know
what are we going to do and together we
put our heads together so what are we
going to do with this film that makes it
special and unique all of the previous
ones had done that
and so together we talked about wanting
to tell the story in a more epic fashion
with more scale to pay attention to the
camerawork and make it a 3d experience
that was really big and fun you know so
it was important for us to be on the
same page at the very beginning with
kind of what our cornerstones would be
for the film and then as we work on the
movie in the editorial process story
process Mike and I are together on all
of those reviews it's only when we get
to the latter part of production where
we've got close to 400 people working on
the movie where now we can divide and
conquer a little bit mike has been an
animator on all of the Ice Age movies
comes from an animation background I
come from an art direction background so
we had a very natural way of kind of
divvying up the work when things got
very busy but really you know with
Lori's experience on this franchise the
characters the heart and soul of what
ice age is all about it's really
together in editorial and in that story
process where we cement what the story
is going to be and how it's going to be
told and the reason that we love working
in animation or it really is for
characters like scratch it's very simple
concept he wants that nut and where can
we take him and how crazy can we get
with him kind of getting in his own way
and and that's where the humor and the
fun comes in but the challenge is not to
repeat yourself we've you know we've had
a variety of Scrat adventures in the
past and we kind of we made it
challenging on ourselves we developed
the very opening of the movie and we had
decided early on that we wanted Scrat to
be integral to the story and we made
this big you know adventure down to the
center of the earth and it was huge and
and as we were working on the movie
we're scratching our heads going ok well
now when we get to the end of the film
we got it we have to top that or we need
to you know pay it off at an equal level
and so that was one of the great
challenges and thanks to the story team
at blue sky and the animators who really
bring Scrat to life I feel like we have
some really fun and entertaining
it's for Scrat and kind of continuing
his legacy